[Music]
kelsey ballerini is putting her heart
first the country star has filed for
divorce from fellow country singer
morgan evans after nearly five years of
marriage people magazine broke the news
with a source saying they've been
working on their marriage for a very
long time prior to this they had
separated privately once before and have
been in therapy for several years they
gave it their best go but unfortunately
arrived at the decision to formally
separate
and shortly after the news broke kelsey
shared an emotional statement on her
instagram writing friends i've always
tried my best to share my life with you
in a real and vulnerable way while also
protecting layers of my personal life as
they unfold this is now public records
so i wanted you to hear from me directly
that i am going through a divorce kelsey
also added that this deeply difficult
decision is the result of a journey of
love growth and effort that ultimately
has come to an end it's hard to find the
words here but i feel extremely grateful
for the years of marriage to morgan and
hopeful for the next seasons with very
active schedules coming up please be
mindful that we are both fragile
actively healing and showing up the best
we can morgan followed suit with his own
statement on instagram confirming kelsey
and i are parting ways i wish it were
otherwise but sadly it is not now the
pair first met back in march of 2016
while co-hosting the cmc music awards in
australia they got engaged that december
on christmas day and exchanged vows in
mexico a year later and kelsey and
morgan made their final red carpet
appearance together as a couple at the
2022 academy of country music awards
back in march this news also comes as
kelsey is gearing up for the upcoming
release of her fifth album subject to
change on september 23rd the material is
set to embody her growth as an artist
while displaying how she has adapted to
change throughout the years
and when we last caught up with kelsey
back in 2020 she opened up about the ups
and downs she and morgan faced as a
couple while forced to spend more time
together at home during the cobin 19
pandemic
we've obviously never had this much time
together we
met as two touring artists and so our
whole relationship has been built on
trying to cram in everything within one
or two days a week of being together and
so it's definitely
been challenging but it's been so
wonderful for us to actually have the
time to exist together and
to get into this rhythm of like what
it's like to be under the same roof and
living together seven days a week it's
it's kind of been five years of marriage
in five months but it's been really
healthy for us and um i definitely feel
like we have a new appreciation for each
other
you